und ich bin das direkt zum place
hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge der
täter schoss zusammen doom und mit dem
wer ist das und wieso fehlt hier ein ein
kreml her
ja ich habe beschwert und das ja gar zu
verzaubert die pvp spezialist also nicht
schlagen wir hatten hier eine
vorstellung er mich mit einer hand gilt
werde ich jemand meine schwert habe da
war eigentlich remmel drin aber
irgendwie das kaputt gegangen und jetzt
haben wir dann zu hinterfragen naja
jedenfalls ist er noch hier und ob also
das ganz kurz erklärt das prinzip mal
ganz kurz zu haben also wir haben hier
am anfang so eine kleine tour platziert
die sind zwar keine sachen drin okay
hier sind ein paar werkzeuge
da kannst du dir jetzt sachen rausnehmen
das ist ein kleines hartz4 häuschen und
dann kannst du dich hier irgendwo hin
bauen wo du willst was denkst du willst
du hin dass hier wieder leben
ihr wert zum beispiel platz jahre also
bei täter in der pyramide da kannst du
dir den weg suchen da sind sehr viele
sachen wenn du willst kannst dich
einfach ihren bonner sich jetzt noch
eine menge
wir müssen aber ein bisschen aufpassen
dass du alles super weil tt hat sich um
so direkt verkauft das war ein bisschen
deswegen sage ich jetzt gerade das hier
ganz gut da warte ich geb dir hier habt
ihr da bleibt stehen
dann gebe ich gern überstehen
ich denke es wäre ganz sinnvoll wenn du
dich hier hinweis es nur das wird sich
wie alle anderen gäste ein haus bauen
und wir haben ein paar themen mal wieder
vorbereitet bzw
nicht nur vorbereitet sondern die sind
gerade im kommen denn ab jetzt werden
wir themen auch auf facebook in empfang
nehmen aber halt stopp schreibt die
themen nicht in irgendwelche sachen
kommentare oder irgendwie postet ihr auf
unserer seite sondern dann wir werden
immer wenn wir aufnehmen das wäre ja
schon mitbekommen im zweifel werden wir
dann einfach post wenigen jetzt auf und
dann könnt ihr da in denen er unter
diesen post in die kommentare eure
themen schreiben das hat luca gerade
schon mal gemacht und gerade hier kann
man das auch noch 217 werden es nur 15
minuten gepostete 217 kommentare er sehr
geil und es sind auch coole themen das
hatte ich eigentlich gedacht ich dachte
kommt mir so was an kam natürlich auch
so etwas wie peter david de gea ist uns
immer ganz interessante sachen harte
rechte die unter anderem von dhl dann
drei gepostet wurden also danke danke an
alle anderen und wenn er das nicht
verpassen wollten wir diese fragen
stellen verpasst wenn ihr design nicht
mehr an den apostel gacon kraft also den
er will ich auch nicht leiden weil das
also schön bescheuert könnte tipps
gleichen seine seite einfach es ist
einfach doppelklicken dann habt ihr den
feldern arbeiten und dann direkt wieder
die abonnieren nachdem jetzt haben und
nun gab auch sofort hin gehen sowieso
wehrmacht pvp sein
alles in meinem rad wenn irgendwas mit
minecraft am hut hat dann der macht
alles zweimal so gut und muss ich werde
ich werde mal also du brauchst jetzt
dahinter
diese schlucken musste nicht aber doch
musst du na ja jedenfalls zog sich da
hinten hin und ich werde versuchen diese
aufnahme da unten wiesen die komischen
weg endlich fertig zu bauen dann wäre
ich noch mal ein netter gehen und dort
einfach nur ein netter werden die kombi
am schnellsten tintenfisch schwarze
wolle
ich kann der x6 geben weil ich habe da
gerade super ist ja wohl sondern auch
wenn du sachen brauchst dann nicht uns
fragen weil wir sind und kooperativ
da kannst du mich einfach die sachen
klauen von thesy kness gamer oder von
koch media den vermissten lucio bei
seinem haus und in immer wenn bei dir im
haus ich glaube bankers ja ich kommen
wobei die klassen irgendwelche sachen
bisschen dass immer die tür zugeknallt
auch hier sind dry ink 636 haben
informiere die schafe damit öffnen haus
kontrolle du kannst ja nochmal fünf
haben
aber dafür muss vorne klatschen zukunft
gehen darf
ich wollte meine kissen sortieren heute
das off screen machen ja ach ja stimmt
das wollte ich auch machen
telefonate aber hier liegen auch
zwischen der aufnahme zwischen den
letzten folgen und diese aufnahmen
liegen monat anbieten und überhaupt man
ändert last sein ob man ja ganz locker
jahren ausgenommen die mieten auge also
ende haben wir schon ein auge
die mainau grafen müssen in den neckar
und lag noch ein blaze partner sein
aber wir müssen so oder so in der ja das
harmlose aufnahmestopp so und zwar nicht
erst schwarz färben mach einfach mal
alle die so gehen gibt so etwas anderes
sex ja auch gar nicht gut wäre da war ja
wohl doch wenn ein buch schreiben ich
glaub buch schreiben mit tinte das macht
sinn hier total ich denke es ist zeit
für das erste thema von facebook oder
von gesichtsbuch soll jetzt raus rufen
oder einfach einzunehmen und nebenbei
alles offen das heißt auch wären wir
aufnehmen könnt ihr dann immer weiter
dann ach so ich vertraue ich übrigens
dass dem er keine sachen cloud oder muss
ich mir im grünen band eine versteckte
kiste bauen weil wenn den er hier unten
ich sehe zum platz frei in meiner kiste
so einfach so wie sein was tust du was
ich war es nicht das war das schaf
schafe sind böse hätten plötzlich haben
nämlich eingebaut oder konnte gerade
noch das schlimmste verhindern
ja also thema
was haltet ihr von ganztagsschulen von
yin und yang total scheiße
eingang in klammern mike ja keine ahnung
auf jetzt allgemein ganztagsschulen oder
ganztagsschulen jetzt irgendwie für die
kleinen kinder verbrachten allgemein im
sinne von normales gymnasium normale
realschule oder wo man hingeht oder halt
eine ganztagsschule also wo man nicht um
15 zu hause ist oder 14 der 16 uhr
sondern halt bis 18 uhr sitzt und
vielleicht seine hausaufgaben da schon
macht sowas nahe kommen vier aus
da ist eine tür irgendwo an sich ist das
natürlich ich bin gerade komplett
woanders rausgekommen an jedoch nicht
ich dachte warum eine helligkeit von
moody
nur 69 so ganz hell so auch in die
scheiße so ja keine ahnung ich würd
sagen an sich jetzt ist eigentlich eine
ganz gute idee kommen packen wir die
kinder einfach länger eine schule müssen
sie noch mehr pumpen noch mehr lernen
und wenn du es einfach wenn wir es
einfach g8 und keine ahnung wenn man
eine ganztagsschule nicht im sinne von
g8 also dass man einfach normal nach
schwerer wären ohne ganztagsschule fast
gar nicht möglich weil die anderen sind
deutschland ist eines der wenigen länder
wo man eigentlich keine ganztagsschüler
sondern sonst überall sind ja die
schüler immer nachmittags in der schule
es muss ja nicht bedeuten dass man dort
unterricht hat sondern zum beispiel
sportvereine so wie wir es kennen ist ja
das alles außerhalb der schule ist also
zum beispiel fußballmannschaft oder
irgendwie sowas und in anderen ländern
zb den usa ist es ja so dass das alles
über die schulen uhr läuft und dann hast
du ja da die freizeit nachmittags auch
in der schule verbracht wird herzlich g8
gymnasium dann machst du gerade g8 wann
hast du ein bisschen noch reizen oder
nach zwölf jahren fertig 13 hast du noch
nicht gemacht denn ich bin 16
dann hat er g8 denen das kommt auf das
land und in schleswig holstein hat 16 im
moment auch noch keinen gemacht
das wird nach und nach eingeführt ich
komme aus niedersachsen ich habe keinen
plan was ja in niedersachsen bis zum
nach zwölf jahren schule fertig also der
jahrgang aus den auf 16 und der jahrgang
über mir die haben jetzt auch schon das
ist der jahrgang über mir ist ein
doppeljahrgang wir haben 300 schüler
einer stufe und die haben jetzt diesem
sommer am schluss dann wächst ist da
quasi hat der jahrgang schluss die drei
g 9 also diese 13 jahre schule da haben
und der jahrgang der g8 hat also einen
doppeljahrgang ist dass dann das soll
natürlich einerseits den arbeitsmarkt
lobby sogar stärken
aber ich weiß dass jede soll den
schwächen denn es ist ja eigentlich
einfach dass du in allen europäischen
ländern oder sonst irgendwo auf der welt
ist
12 noch früher fertig und in deutschland
erst ab 13 und wow hat mir freunde
gebracht die über herum
aber vielen dank fehlen halt toll danke
sobald kerngeschehen halben haben aber
und das soll ja eigentlich die die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit steigern aber halt
dass du einfach anders das halt früher
mit der schule fertig bist und früher
auf dem arbeitsmarkt bis eine steigerung
die tiere vom vom wettbewerb
untereinander
daraus resultiert ja eigentlich schon
das was gesagt überlegen
dadurch resultiert doch dadurch
resultiert ja eine stärkung des
wirtschafts sollte sich daraus
resultiert ja oh ich hasse diese scheiß
zombies
dadurch resultiert ja dass ich der der
der arbeitsmarkt ersteigert und ich sag
mal der arbeitsmarkt wird der wettbewerb
wird größer stimmt ich habe eine fräse
ich hab eine festung gefunden allgemein
stronghold nein du bist ja ich hab nicht
an einem vorbei ich bin so gut
vorbereitet
super nicht
ich weiß nicht was sie da überhaupt
alles treibt so ich bin im neckar und
ich werde vom gas abgeschossen ich wähle
riesige festung vor mir wie weit ist den
weg merkte vier die waldi ist nicht weit
weg aber diese riesig das geld das die
teile so riesig sind hat die sind die
höheren gar nicht auf niemand diese
scheiß ding machen wir alles kaputt
ich höre schon place trotz place watts
wenn eine normale place na ja genau
genommen
das heißt ich glaube ich bin direkt bei
seiner kürzlich konnte
wie krass großen wie es direkt los doch
wenn ich jetzt verrät ich habe alle
meine sachen von mir dabei ich kriege
irgendwie nicht hin dass gute fernseher
zu bauen so fernsehen fernsehen so weil
ich habe mir vorgenommen hier mal ein
bisschen in eine richtung zu machen
jetzt aber danach will ich auch dir doch
einfach das top job media video an
also dann versuche ich jetzt wieder mehr
sondern ist ein dings zu krallen und
dann machen wir erstmal der inder test
oder rauscht und branchen award aus
brauchen wir aus stand es aber auch
nicht schwer zu bauen
tränke zu brauchen ist ein etwas schwer
das habe ich aber deutlich gemacht die
mystery mit cash und tatsächlich geld du
läufst dann unsichtbar oben bist' feuer
resistent alles alles alles auch schon
mal gesehen
und ich bin das direkt zum place tings
ich hab' ich habe als getötet aber es
hat keinen place fallen lassen
jetzt weiß ich mich wie ihr euch wie ihr
euch immer finden wenn wenn ihr
irgendwas rum baut und arbeiten unter
www erfahrung alter da zieht machen
doppelt so viel erfahrung wie normale
und überall meinem haus weg dreck rum
kann ich gar nicht überall items muss
einsortieren
wir sehen diese komischen never was kann
ich denn machen die brauchen wir
brauchen nämlich alle mit allen
mitnehmen kann man einmal noch sondern
er okay so stand habe ich bei euch
einmal hin alles drin gestanden
immerhin alles drin war sommer penny
rewe real real möchte jetzt auf reden ja
ganztagsschulen ja keine ahnung ist
eigentlich sinnvoll
ich finde es eigentlich also sinnvoll
aber für die schüler natürlich die
finden das nicht so geil
naja du hast ja nachmittags nicht nur
schule ist sondern dann halt ja aber
dann legt der kommentar frage als
definitiv nicht auf amerika bezogen
sondern der meinte damit wahrscheinlich
die deutsche ganztagsschule und
definierte ganztagsschule dann von wegen
jahr man 70 bis 500 schule und muss
irgendwelche sachen machen und das finde
ich ehrlich gesagt natürlich einerseits
gut weil man dadurch natürlich schneller
in den arbeitsmarkt kommt schon die
erfahrung macht mit den arbeiten man die
leute die schüler natürlich schneller
auf das echte leben vorbereitet sein
allerdings aus sicht der schüler also so
wie ich jetzt kennen so von freuen und
auch von mir selber merke ich natürlich
der stress ist ihm etwas in meinem haus
bin ich hab irgendwann bastings gesehen
aber ich finde jetzt gerade in zwei ich
hab nur blech gesehen scheisse scheisse
zählt hier passieren merkwürdige dinge
sein fall einmal abdallah kallel er
definitiv sind übrigens auch wieder bei
15 minuten sich gerade 14 30 da und da
ich jetzt gerade er an seiner alter ist
die festung bitte groß ja nächste folge
werden dann bei mir die feste bei der
kunden und dann nächstfolgende bei den
rheinhessen oder zerstört ungefähren
sachen geklaut ich hab den links
gefunden ich hab schon wieder so ein
letzten dollar bar mit dem man auch mal
vorbeischauen kann machen die viel
schaden hilfe und so bis zur nächsten
folge
wenn ihr auch mal kommentar freyenstein
wollt dann könnt ihr auf unserer
facebook seite vorbeischauen und am
besten erreichen damit ihr seht wenn wir
mal wieder nach kommentare frage findest
du schon mal da ein bisschen diesmal
macht